hello hello everyone um I am K kosn I'm
going to start with a brief
introduction uh before I pass it over to
my colleague Dr anise chakar for her
presentation uh I am a faculty at the Y
School of Public Health and I am the
faculty director for humanitarian
research lab uh with a particular
interest to address the health of
populations that are affected by
humanitarian crisis including armed
conflict and I've had a focus on the
Mena region in the Middle East North
Africa region my own training is an
infectious disease
epidemiology but um every time I speak
with humanitarian organizations um they
ncds non-clinical diseases come up and
cancer Cancer Care and treatment has
come up multiple times uh when I have uh
visited this uh
humanitarian um Nos and I recall um
there was kind of a disturbing story
when I when I visited Lebanon and I went
to a humanitarian organization and there
was a Syrian oncologist who had been
displaced into Lebanon and he had
started the mamography
um uh clinic for Syrian refugees I think
he was the only one doing that and he
had um been screening women for breast
cancer and she he told me that one of
these women had early stage breast
cancer and he referred her to uh un
agencies that provide uh financial
support for cancer treatment and they
told this woman that you know you're
you're very early stage breast cancer we
cannot fund you come back uh whatever A
year later or so uh if your breast
cancer is Advanced then we can Provide
support for you and that was such a
disturbing uh story that I heard it's
completely sort of an anti-public Health
uh issue um because we are supposed to
be able to screen and treat breast
cancer patient as early as possible not
wait but these un agencies have very
limited funds and they make these
decisions about you know people are in
late stage breast cancer and are likely
to die they kind of uh focus on them uh
the limited resources that they have so
I was very disturbed by that and I was
trying to figure out what I can do to
support this project and I ended up
working with um one of our students long
ago named Jude alawa who comes from a
Syrian family background and he ended up
doing the first study looking at uh
cancer awareness and access to treatment
for cancer patients in Lebanon both in
the Syrian refugee population and the
Lebanese population and that was a very
sort of meaningful study that he did and
it triggered conversation uh about
different stakeholders to continue this
work um I then learned that uh our
colleagues uh called Sam's Syrian
American Medical Society have launched
uh a clinic an oncology clinic in 2018
in Northwest Syria which uh as you may
know it's a conflict Zone Northwest
Syria is not under government control
and Sam's Syrian American Medical
Society is one of the few organizations
that is able to provide uh care and
treatment and they actually had um set
up a clinic to take care of cancer
patients so I reached out to them to see
what support we can provide for them and
what they wanted was um they had been
collecting a lot of data but they hadn't
really had the time and capacity to
analyze this data they wanted us to
support them and put out reports and I
reached out to my colleague Dr anise
chakar who's a wonderful um uh surgeon
oncologist and I asked whether she would
be interested in uh participating this
project and she said yes she applied for
a grant from the McMillan uh Center and
was able to launch this study that she's
going to tell you about uh just briefly
um I want to mention to you Dr Anise
chakar is a food professor in department
of surgery at the yel school of medicine
she has specific expertise in breast
cancer as you can see she has multiple
master's degree in addition to her
medical degree she has a masters in
public health she has Masters in
bioethics and medical Humanities she has
an MBA from Yale um so she really um and
she's also the Fantastic Communicator uh
you may have come across uh her course
sah course on breast cancer which is
extremely
popular and uh she's quite active on
social media and she's very passionate
about global health and leadership in
academic training uh and uh I'm really
delighted that she agreed to lead this
project and today she's going to uh
present to you what this uh where this
project has gone over the last two years
uh Dr chakor I'll pass it on to you
thank you so much so much cave um so
it's a it's a real pleasure uh to be
here to uh present this work uh this um
as cave mentioned um was a collaborative
effort uh between uh the school of
medicine the School of Public Health as
well as our colleagues uh from around
the world um through the the
syrian-american medical
society and it was really a mixed
methods investigation into the
experience and outcomes of patients with
breast cancer in the Sam's Clinic in
northwest
Syria so before we dive in um here are
my disclosures the ones at the top uh
really will not be relevant uh to
today's discussion I'm not going to be
discussing anything that is pertinent um
to that those funding sources um but I
do want to highlight uh as cave
mentioned that the work that I'll be
presenting was funded in part by the
Yale McMillan Center Program on refugees
Force displacement and humanitarian
response and we are very grateful uh for
that
support so if we take a step back and we
think about the Syrian conflict this has
really been going on since 2011 and it
started as a civilian Uprising rooted in
the Arab
Spring and we know that this really took
on a an AR armed conflict um and and
involved targeted strikes particularly
on Health Care personnel and Facilities
it caused over 400,000 deaths and there
were more than 5.6 million refugees out
of the pre-war population of 22 million
um that 5.6 million is likely an
underestimate and the World Health
Organization in
2017 um called the Syrian conflict the
worst man-made disaster the world has
ever seen since World War
II the chart which I show you um below
is really the change um in um in level
of Life satisfaction in 163 countries uh
blue being better um life satisfaction
um red being worse and so you can see
that um over this period of time
um life satisfaction in Syria has
declined
significantly if we think about breast
cancer in Syria in particular these are
data um from Global can um breast cancer
as many of you know Remains the leading
cause
of of cancer in women worldwide and that
is certainly the case in Syria it's also
the leading cause of mortality and here
you can see that this is not just among
women but uh breast cancer in Syria is
the leading malignancy period across all
genders and the leading uh cause of
cancer related mortality across all
genders so if we think about the map of
Syria I've highlighted here the uh
Capital Damascus in red which you can
see in the south um Aleppo is a large
city in in the north and it was these
two centers that really had a lot of the
um Health Care uh especially prior to
the conflict where sams's came in was um
in establishing a clinic here in idb in
the Northwestern part of Syria where as
as cave mentioned this was really a
conflict um area
and so the objectives of this study were
to understand the patient experience and
Pathways to diagnosis of patients with
breast cancer at the Sam supported
facilities in Northwest Syria and to
evaluate factors affecting stage at
presentation and outcomes of these
patients so we did this with both a
qualitative study as well as a
quantitative one and I want to walk you
through um both parts of the stud study
so for the qualitative study um we set
inclusion criteria of patients who were
diagnosed with breast cancer at the
Sam's uh facilities who were living in
Northwest Syria who were at least 18
years of age or older 90 patients were
screened and 65 patients were excluded
um the reasons for the exclusion were
that 40 of them did not have a working
telephone number or Whatsapp 25 had
either died or declined due to current
illness or lack of incentive to
participate and three um could not find
a time to be interviewed within the time
period alloted so we were left with 22
patients who uh were interviewed between
August and September of last
year informed consent was taken by uh
all participants this was a study that
was approved by the human investigations
uh committee the interviews were
conducted in conversational Arabic in
the local dialect and they were done on
WhatsApp uh they were recorded
transcribed coded for themes uh envivo
software was used and they looked at a a
framework analysis method uh with a
feminist
lens here are the demographics of the
participants so the mean a was 45 with a
range of 24 to
67 roughly half little less than half
41% were internally displaced you can
see that there were no patients in this
uh study um where stage was known who
had early stage disease all of these
patients had either stage two three or
four disease the majority of whom over
50% were stage two and
three um 18% % were not educated only
14% had a university education the
majority of these women had children um
and were married um and the majority of
them were working as a housewife or or
were
retired so that gives you a sense of the
population who were
interviewed and as these interviews were
conducted there were a number of themes
that
emerged one was really this whole idea
of the challenges in terms of accessing
oncology care um and many of the
participants were very grateful uh to
Sam's for having established um oncology
care in Northwest Syria they mentioned
things like the fact that there was a
center there actually reduced some of
the challenges including costs of
transport support and services in Turkey
um being away from family and feeling
isolated because of the linguistic
barrier in Turkey delays in permissions
to cross the border and restrictions on
companions remember that many of these
uh patients um if they couldn't get care
in in Syria uh turkey would be their
their uh
alternative but that was not all roses
there were Transportation issues within
Syria too that were
problematic another issue that came up
was really the financial strain and I
wanted to highlight some of the quotes
that we got from participants who were
interviewed so participant number eight
for example said we struggled a lot
because my husband doesn't have a
regular income one day he works and
another he doesn't we are staying in
tents and now because of the
chemotherapy I feel too hot in the tent
however I try not to complain the living
conditions are very difficult no one
helps us with the cost of treatment we
had a freezer and a refrigerator but we
sold them so that I can continue my
treatment and that gives you a sense of
what life is like for many of these
people um living in Syria in this
conflict area and and the struggles that
they face um in terms of day-to-day
living as well as in affording the cost
of
treatment there were also delays in care
um one of the things that I should point
out here is that radiation therapy is
not available in Northwest Syria and
it's not available at the Sam's oncology
center in Northwest Syria either so for
people who need radiation therapy um the
only option is to go to Turkey so
participant number one for example said
there is only one doctor to see almost
200 patients a day at the hospital that
I was referred to she's talking here
about the hospital that she was referred
to in
Turkey she goes on to say one time I
stayed two months in Turkey until my
turn arrived and by that time the doctor
said you will need another radiotherapy
treatment a and this was a recurring
theme this idea of delays in care um
being problematic for for these
patients another theme that came out
that was um interesting was in human
relationships um a couple of the
participants uh noted the real positive
um uh aspects of their family
relationships that came out um during
their cancer Journey so participant
number 13 for example said my husband
did The Impossible
and he left the family and went with me
to Turkey he never left me alone the
amount of support I got from him made me
feel that there is someone who really
believes that I can recover and survive
this had an important
role participant number 17 had a similar
uh experience she says my parents-in-law
supported me and my husband in
particular helped me in Turkey as my
parents are not around he was the first
one to support me thank God the
emotional and psychological part of this
disease is important as long as you have
someone next to you supporting you you
will forget about the disease and he was
there next to me all the
time and so we can see that for some
patients they had incredibly strong
family support which really helped them
to get through the breast cancer Journey
but it wasn't all good so participant 18
for
example said cancer wasn't as shocking
for me as when my husband left me you
feel you are not useful for anything
anymore this is harder than the disease
cancer
itself and she wasn't the only one so
participant number four said I have
three children in the beginning my
sister took care of my son who was s
months old and the other children were
taken care of by my
parents then the community started
saying my husband needs to marry again
and have another wife to take care of
the children he did this and took the
children so they are far away from me
now and so you can see that it's not
just the cancer Journey that many of
these patients had to deal with it was
also some of the human relationships um
the culture cult Al uh relationships the
family relationships um that they also
had to contend
with so that gave us a little bit of a
taste of what the experience of these
patients were um as they went through
the cancer Journey um in
Syria the second part of the study was
really quantitative trying to get at
what is the presentation clinically of
these patients how does that compare to
what we see here in the US and what
factors really impact stage at diagnosis
Etc so in order to answer the
quantitative part of this project we
reviewed charts of women who were
diagnosed with breast cancer at the
Sam's oncology center in idlib between
2018 and
20121 so we looked at 192 patients the
median age at diagn nois was 46 with a
range between 22 and 80 so just to put
that into context right if you think
about the AG at diagnosis of breast
cancer here in the US these are data
that I'm showing you from the American
Cancer Society you can see that the
median agent diagnosis here is 62 so a
lot younger um in terms of time date at
diagnosis for patients in Syria
clinically 16% of these patients
presented with clinical distant metastic
disease 70% had palpable lymph nodes at
the time of their presentation and at
the time of surgery
76% were found to have
pathologically uh involved lymph nodes
and the median number of lymph nodes
that were found to be positive was four
the invasive tumor size was uh median
was 4 cm the range from 0.5 to 18 cm so
for those of you who may not be as
familiar with uh breast cancer and its
stage in the US just to put this into
context and here again I'm showing you
data from the ACs you can see here in
the light pink bars across different
races distant metastatic disease ranging
anywhere between five and
8% and you can see that in Syria the
rate of having distant metastatic
disease was roughly double that um and
so we know that that is certainly
significant prognosis of patients who
have distant metastatic disease is far
inferior and in fact when people have
distant metastatic
disease although the disease may be
treatable it is not
curable um you can see see in the medium
pink bars um anywhere between 24 and
31% of patients in the US will present
with what's called Regional disease so
lymph node positive disease in Syria
again more than twice that at
76% and even when we have patients here
in the US who have node positive disease
oftentimes that node positivity is only
one or two lymph nodes whereas in Syria
the median number of lymph nodes
involved was four in the US many
patients are presenting with even
pre-invasive cancers
dcis or stage one remember back to the
qualitative uh portion of this study
where none of those patients had that
early stage disease that's also
reflected in this quantitative analysis
where the median size was 4 cm so we're
thinking more into that uh stage two to
three uh breast
cancer in terms of um histology so of
the 192 charts that we reviewed um where
we had information about histology only
three patients 1.6% presented with dcis
dcis is pre-invasive cancer uh
essentially curable in the US that
number number is about
177% um in Syria of the invasive breast
cancers roughly 81% were invasive ductal
133% were invasive lobular those are are
similar to what we see here in the US um
they had about 12% who were triple
negative that is to say that their
tumors did not express ER PR or her two
uh receptors on their surface um the
number in the US is roughly similar
slightly lower at
10% when we looked at how these patients
were diagnosed and treated you can see
that 92% had the diagnosis made based on
exision there's been now an
international consensus that ideally we
want to diagnose these patients using
minimally invasive techniques like
needle biopsies usually a core needle
biopsy and in Syria only 4% of the
patients were diagnosed based on cornal
biopsy now our analysis did not get into
why that was I can tell you based on uh
experiences that we've had in other
areas of of the world uh for example my
brother does a lot of work in global
health in
Tajikistan where cornal biopsies the
actual device itself are just very hard
to find there is's simply a lack of
supplies and so that may have played a
role here but again we don't have
information on that despite these
cancers being fairly large and um
locally Advanced at presentation where
we here in the west would have treated
those patients with chemotherapy first
many of those patients went on to
receive surgery as their initial
treatment 94% of them and again further
work needs to to occur to really dig
into why that was it may have
been the fact that chemotherapy may not
have been available it may have been due
to anxiety on the P part of patients or
the fact that they were facing you know
fungating breast lesions where um what
we would call here in the west a toilet
um mastectomy or or a pallative
mastectomy was required simply to
control uh the local
disease again we do not have information
on the rationale behind uh these figures
um but rather this is more hypothesis
generating uh rather than um
definitive what we do know is that they
had a very respect able uh time between
diagnosis and surgery a median of 15
days is certainly acceptable even here
in the west but you can see that that
range was from zero perhaps by people
who had an excision of their cancer
which was also Curative at the same time
all the way up to
756 days so that is more than two years
um which certainly is
problematic we then looked at a number
of other interesting questions that we
were able to parse out from the data
that we
collected one was exposure to chemical
weapons now in the analysis in the data
that we had gathered only seven patients
had exposure to chemical weapons and so
that's something certainly to keep in
mind these are small numbers and so um
as you can see we did not achieve
statistic
significance um on the basis of any of
these clinical pathologic factors but it
may well have been related to the fact
that we were comparing to such a small
sample size but if you look at the
actual numbers themselves you can see
that uh those who did have exposure to
chemical weapons albeit that these are
not statistically
significant tended to be higher grade
more often triple negative more often to
have Clinic iCal distant metastases more
often to be node positive more often to
be larger in size which raises the
question if we expanded this study would
we in fact reach statistical
significance again hypothesis generating
um rather than uh
definitive the next question that we
looked at was seeing the difference
between citizens or host population
and those who were internally displaced
so here you can see that um in the
cohort of charts that we looked at over
half of these uh patients were in fact
displaced um this goes back to um the
fact that in the Northwest Syria that is
roughly uh the percentage of the
population who are
displaced and you can see here that we
found no statistically sign ific
difference in terms of any of these
clinical pathologic factors which goes
to say that people are people um whether
you were displaced or not displaced the
type of breast cancer that we saw
amongst these two populations were very
similar and you can look at the
individual parameters here and you can
see that they they're very similar um
one of the things that was interesting
however um when we looked uh at the
differences between the host population
and the internally displaced people was
that there was a trend albe it not a
statistically significant Trend but
still a trend with a P value of
0.0051 towards a shorter time from
diagnosis to the initiation of treatment
for internally displaced people now on
the face of it that may seem
counterintuitive you would think that
those who are internally displaced would
have a harder time accessing care they
should have a longer time to
treatment but I think that there are a
few things to keep in mind here one is
that again remember this may not truly
be a shorter time interval we did not
hit statist statistical significance
it's only a trend and it is still a
relatively small sample size however the
other thing that I think that is
important to keep in mind is that these
patients had already accessed care they
had already been diagnosed with breast
cancer at the Sam's facility and so the
ray of light here might be that those
people who were diagnosed at the Sams
facility in Northwestern Syria it didn't
seem to really impede those who were
internally displaced in terms of getting
their treatment if anything their
treatment was slightly shorter uh for 18
days versus 19 days from the time of
diagnosis than the host population and
this may have been related to other
issues right the host population um
might have included citizens who were
employed um who might have had other
obligations where it may have delayed
them somewhat in terms of getting their
treatment and clinically the difference
between 19 days and 14 days is not uh
terribly dramatic um so I think it's at
least reassuring that um internally
displaced people once the diagnosis is
made um could get uh treatment in a
relatively expeditious
fashion so in summary um there are a
number of unique challenges faced by
breast cancer survivors in Northwestern
Syria in terms of access to Care
Transportation Financial strain family
tensions and when we look at breast
cancer in Syria at least in the
Northwestern part of Syria and the Sam's
oncology centers
there the presentation tends to be
younger women at a higher stage more
often triple negative um more often
diagnosed with exision than what we
would see here in the US um again this
study only scratches the surface I think
that there is still plenty of work to be
done um if we compare those who were
exposed to chemical weapons versus not
there were no statistically significant
differences in terms of clinical
pathologic factors But there again I
wonder whether that is just related to
the small sample size because when we
look at the actual numbers um we do see
uh differences that that may be
meaningful but citizens or host
populations and those who were
internally displaced had very similar um
clinical pathologic characteristics and
at least for those who were treated in
the Sams facility in idlib there was no
difference in the time to treatment uh
between those populations and if
anything there was a trend to the
internally displaced populations getting
a slightly shorter uh time interval
between diagnosis and treatment
so this study would not have been
possible without a wealth of
collaborators uh Cave mentioned um how
this study got started uh Jude alawa who
um uh Cave mentioned uh should be on
this slide so my apologies uh for for
that Omission uh you can see here um our
Sam's uh colleagues as well as a number
of students at Yale who participated um
in making this work possible
so I'm going to stop there and I am
happy to answer any questions that you
might have hi uh I just have a general
uh question so you mention about the
difference uh between U uh no difference
uh of between Cancer Treatment um for
the uh uh people who are uh internally
displaced and and the host Community um
I don't know if um within uh with these
Sams uh do they collect also information
for other diseases is that like
something that you see as well yeah so
so our project only focused on breast
cancer patients so the charts that we
reviewed were all breast cancer patients
um I do know that the Sam's facility
there does treat other kinds of cancers
um and may although I'm not sure in cave
you might know better than me may also
um treat other other diseases as well um
I know that they do treat other cancers
um but we did not look at that that
might be something for future study as
well maybe I can ask a question till
others are processing I'm sure um thank
you so much for that presentation and uh
it's really to my knowledge San American
Medical Society is one of the
few U International humanitarian
organizations that actually offers
Cancer Care and treatment I think
there's a lot of humanitarian
organizations that for a variety of
reasons don't see Cancer Care treatment
as part of their you know um
responsibilities I think Doctors Without
Borders msf does that so of course I'm
interested in figuring out how do we how
do we make this case to other
humanitarian organizations that Cancer
Care and treatment is not something that
should be neglected because the
population you're talking about they're
um they're stuck for decade so they're
they don't just have sort of acute let's
infectious disease issues they have
chronic conditions cancer of course is
one of them but I'm sure there's
diabetes there's hypertension there's
all kinds of ncds but in
General um humanitarian organizations
don't seem to focus as much on ncds as
they ought to so I don't know if you
have any thoughts about that how do we
make that case that um ncds should
become a priority for humanitarian
organization and the other question I
had was on breast cancer
prevention I'm just wondering if there's
um any strategies that can be done in
reducing
breast cancer in displaced populations
in humanitarian
settings yeah so two two very uh
important uh questions you know the
first one I is really difficult right
because we know um particularly for
cancer it's an expensive disease to
treat and it is an expensive disease to
treat
because it requires a multidisiplinary
effort it requires a lot of
infrastructure it requires
Specialists um and so for humanitarian
organizations who are trying to deliver
care one can imagine that you know when
they look at their limited
resources that they say to themselves
where's the best place to spend our
buck and you know kind of get the
biggest wins that we can in the shortest
period of time that we can for the least
amount of money as we
can and so I think that that um
therefore takes people into the root of
well let's make sure that there's clean
water let's make sure that there's
sanitation let's make sure that you know
we can feed children um let's make sure
that we can treat infectious
diseases um and those things are
important but to your point you know as
we see these conflicts that are not
limited in time um that are extensive we
know that the mortality associated with
non-communicable
diseases is going to far overtake the
mortality associated with communicable
diseases um but I think that the case is
difficult to make to these humanitarian
organizations because it is a big list
lift right it it is a lot of money um to
expend and particularly for things like
cancer which is so complex you cannot
think about breast cancer being the same
as prostate cancer or lung cancer or
colon cancer or
leukemia and and so now you're treating
many different
diseases um it it becomes um it becomes
difficult to have the expertise the
infrastructure Etc whereas other
non-communicable diseases heart disease
hypertension diabetes might be easier
and I think the last point that I'll
make is that the impact that you see
many of these humanitarian organizations
they want to see impact
because that's how they that's their
lifeblood right they they are they are
relying on funders they are relying on
people philanthropic donations and part
of to fund their mission and part of the
way that they harness that is to say
look at the impact that we're having and
cancer is one of these where you know
impact is measured not in days but in
years and it can take a long time to see
your impact and so I think those are the
issues that these humanitarian
organizations
face I think one of the ways to get over
that is to do a better job in terms of
taking care of the
immediate issues so that once those
immediate issues are
done then these humanitarian
organizations can kind of say well what
else is there to do and then and then
work at at the next issue which will be
the non-communicable diseases now this
is not to say that I don't think that
they should do work in cancer this is my
lifeblood but I I understand um I
understand the difficulty that these NOS
face in terms of prevention this is
another one that's hard right um because
if we think
about primary prevention which is really
what I think you're getting after how do
you prevent the disease from the first
place it's really hard if we think about
primary prevention of breast cancer
reducing risk factors well what are the
two main risk factors for developing
breast cancer being born female at Birth
and getting
older like what are you going to do um
family history plays in um if we can
avoid uh nuclear disasters radiation um
plays into to breast cancer so if we can
have world peace that might help um but
the
modifiable risk factors are Feud right
and they're the ones that everybody
knows about right so if you can reduce
obesity increase physical activity
maintain maintain ideal body weight we
know that you will reduce your risk of
many cancers n PS you will also reduce
your risk of many ncds that are also key
Killers right heart disease diabetes
stroke etc
etc but we also know that you know our
world population is um getting more and
more obese so if we could do something
on that front that potentially is a very
costeffective way of having a meaningful
impact will it have an impact that will
be measurable in days no but it may have
an impact that will be measurable in
years other things alcohol well okay but
particularly in the Middle East with a a
large Muslim
population that may not be as much of an
issue um as as it might be in Western
countries um exogenous hormones taking
hormone replacement therapy again
something that in you know um developing
countries may not be as prevalent as it
is here in the west and even here in the
west we've seen that after the Women's
Health um initiative study came out
demonstrating that exogenous um hormones
increase the risk of breast cancer we
saw that rate Decline and similarly saw
a decline in breast cancer incidents but
there are but if we think about as a
whole um breast cancer is one of those
where you know there there aren't a lot
of things we can do in terms of primary
prevention the other thing is you know
on the family history side and the
genetics we've done studies um for
example in Trinidad and Tobago in
Pakistan where we found a high
prevalence of triple negative breast
cancers in younger populations trying to
see whether they had a higher rate of
genetic mutations if they have a genetic
mutation it doesn't mean that we now
magically can resolve this but women can
do things that will prophylactically
reduce their risk right so you can do
prophylactic mastectomies which will
reduce your risk by
95% however then you come into the other
problem which is in many of these areas
in the Middle East in
Asia there are cultural
Stigmata that play into this right and
so even patients who face a diagnosis of
breast cancer many of them will
say I was really scared to have
treatment because if I lost my breast
then I would not have been marriageable
and if I was not marriageable then I
would have been excluded from the
community right and
so the aspect of well if we only knew
the genetics of the population we could
take steps to prophylactically reduce
risk
also H has problems right so this is one
of the things that I always find
challenging about global health is that
for everything that you think of as a
potential solution there are nine other
problems that that emerge it's kind of
like this onion that you you keep
peeling the layers of the onion and
there's still more layers
underneath so k i don't you you've had
more experience than me in this whole
area what are your
thoughts
well I mean I develop my humanit
research lab because I want the research
to be beneficial to humanitarian
organizations and policy makers and I I
think that to me is a critical thing I'm
so glad that you've done this research
and I'm really hopeful that Sam's is
able to use these um evidence and to to
apply for you know additional
funds uh to get more support because now
they have some data to share so that's
that's really
um I feel like just bringing some
attention to this and doing research
that he organizations may not have the
time or the capacity to do that that's
our role as an academic
institution
yeah and C can I ask as well because um
these are areas that are clearly have
been affected U vastly by the conflict
so how hard is for this institutions
that are able to give the the support to
continue doing that because of obviously
it's very different if you are in a in a
peaceful setting and then to be able to
plan ahead rather than just trying to
survive and when you were saying about I
mean all of the diseases that they they
look at I mean you would imagine that
probably trauma would be one of the very
first one to that
they have to or they take care of both
physically and and and hopefully
mentally as well yeah yeah no I
um I think that Sams you
know
has been blessed to have a a reasonable
philanthropic arm um that helps to to
fund some of of its work and they are
very committed um to really improving um
particularly Cancer Care in in
Northwestern Syria
um but to your point I I think that you
know we saw that even Sam's facilities
um had been embroiled in this in in the
conflict right we know that the conflict
had targeted health care facilities and
you know so it's it's really tragic when
you know you're trying to help
populations and you're you're finding
yourself on on the receiving end of the
conflict that you're trying to
help and and to the part of the cost
they're able to provide all of these
services without
any yeah so they they offer their
services free of charge um but again I
think that they are very reliant on on
donors and on
fundraising um and on grants and um but
so far um my understanding is that they
do offer all of this care free of
charge Angie I see your
hand hi this is this is just terrific
thank you so much for sharing and for
doing such important work um I have a
question more around
methods um and I love how you have um
you know triangulated you've looked at
the epidemiology of it you have thought
of the possibilities of the molecular
genetics of it but you've also done some
of the qualitative work around it so I
love I love the way that you are um
truly approaching this from mix methods
approach can you talk a little bit about
what the qualitative um process looked
like um you know was this mostly like
looking for emergent uh themes in the
experiences of women uh or did you come
in with some a prior maybe ideas or
assumptions of what was um highly
relevant to them and then the second
part to that question is what does your
loc sort of the Syrian academic
engagement look like what potential what
role do you see there um in in uh kind
of complex um you know public health
questions like this one thank you yeah
so um so full disclosure I was not
directly participating in the
qualitative uh portion this was really
done by our colleagues um through Sam's
um my Arabic is um much worse than their
English um uh because my Arabic is
pretty much non-existent um but my
understanding is that the um the
interviews were
conducted without any necessarily a
prior
[Music]
um understanding of of themes that would
emerge but really those are themes that
came out um of the conversations as they
occurred and um and and the uh the
researchers who had much more of an
experiencing qualitative research than I
did um kind of Applied this this
framework methods um to to the uh
interviews that they got used in Vivo to
help code for themes had consultation
between investigators to really parse
out what were the themes that were
emerging and kind of went from there in
terms of the second question of academic
um uh Partnerships you know I think that
this is this is still emerging um so
this was the first project that um I had
done with with Sams they have research
researchers um both uh located within
Syria at the at the University there as
well as in the UK and in the US and so
we were able to kind of partner together
in a a transnational way to answer
questions that were important to all
parties tave I don't know if you want to
add
anything I think you covered the what I
was thinking about I was also thinking
about how we were I know you were
particularly interested in trying to
hire Syrian medical students in
Northwest area to participate in this
and there was a lot of policy issues
around uh being able to
fund students in Syria and so that was
that was a bit challenging but we
somehow still managed it took a couple
of months to figure out how to do the
qualitative work but um yeah yeah
i i i to to to that point Angie I think
that cavey brings up a good point is you
know there are um regulations between
you know what can pass between the US
and Syria because of embargos and and so
on and so forth and and we complied with
that right like there are there are
rules that you know you have to color
within the lines but um but hopefully
you know you can still collaborate and
find interesting ways that uh you can
partner to answer important
questions wonderful thank you thank you
so
much thank you everybody for joining us
especially Angie ponga I'm so glad to
see you Angie has done some wonderful
work on Early Child Development in
Lebanon and in many other countries um
so thanks for joining us uh Dr chart
thank you so much this was incredible
and I really hope that this research um
will make a difference for the Syrian
population who are struggling with
cancer and many other issues so thank
you all right thanks everyone take care
have a great day bye bye thank thank you
very much uh for the presentation
excellent thank you Teresa
byebye